[Musique]
québec l'université
elle est spécialisée dans la formation
appliquée au management de la cyber
sécurité
on va proposer donc des formations de
management on va proposer aussi des
thématiques un peu plus spécialisés dans
la cybersécurité notamment le fort
demanda si la sécurité notamment la
cryptologie
aujourd'hui la formation sur la sécurité
on va commencer par la formation
cryptologie ces informations qui sera
proposé par un expert international dans
le domaine de la cybersécurité qui a
déjà donné des cours notamment au japon
elle va avoir lieu donc le 21 et le 22
janvier
et ça se passera à ce calcul c'est une
formation qui est destiné aux cadres
déjà qu'ils ont des activités de
management transversal pour qu'il puisse
qu'on puisse les sensibiliser sur la
sécurité
constatant un besoin très important
notamment donc via nos partenaires et
nos clients
et aujourd'hui ça se justifie par à la
recherche de compétences notamment dans
ce domaine ne proposons aujourd'hui
notre dossier auprès de france
compétences nos objectifs à moyen terme
c'est d'avoir un impayé management de la
cyber sécurité